love this guy love working with him love
all all the things about him especially
his accuracy and his honesty and the
fact that he likes calling into this
show when i ask him to
i hope ian rappaport my colleague from
the nfl media group joining us from new
york city where the league meetings just
wrapped up how are you sir
uh since we're talking about accuracy
and honesty you guys actually called me
i just merely answered the quote no i
know that oh you know well i mean that's
true you you're not you didn't pick up
the phone and dial us i guess that is
right i didn't die i received the call
very good he'd like happy to talk to you
about it thank you sir greatly
appreciate it all right let's start with
deshaun watson
um
so your tweet that the the panthers are
are no longer pursuing they're out
um your last line the quarterback has
only waived his no trade clause for the
dolphins is that the reason why the
panthers are out they tried to get
desean to
wave for them and we're rebuffed is that
what we should read between those 280
character lines ian
here are here are the reasons and there
are several and first of all i want to
be clear the panthers are out right now
my understanding is they are out through
the next six days like if deshawn
watkins is not traded by the trade
deadline and this goes into the next
offseason which
would make this officially the longest
story in the history of the world but
anyway if that happens i would expect
the panthers to come and be back in the
trade would be expensive not prohibitive
but expensive that's one
the other thing is
they would like to talk to him they
would like to sit down with him they'd
like to get everything there is to
possibly know
about deshaun want they would like to
hear from him
on the field off the field all the
questions that they might have right
they have not been able to do that and
are not going to be able to do that over
the next six days
so that is another reason yes he has
only as of right now waved
his no trade clause for the miami
dolphins uh if the panthers
would have traded for him
you can't do it not knowing whether or
not he would accept a trade
um so that is those are the reasons why
they have pulled out and why i reported
what i did okay so then let's take this
one step at a time then um does that
mean that dolphins have been able to
talk to deshaun watson have have has
that because you you'd have to figure
anybody would not believe
i know the dolphins have done extensive
work
on deshaun watson his situation
i do not believe there has been any
official [ __ ] what's happened without me
knowing but i do not believe there's
been any official contact between
deshaun watson and the miami dolphins
because you'd have to ask permission and
the texans would have to grant it and
desean would have to grant it too i
imagine you have to
if he's waving his no trade clause he he
would be granting an appearance with him
and you'd have to figure a team would
have to
ask him questions about what what's the
i mean you could do as much gum shoe
work as you possibly can nothing beats
face to face eye to eye man-to-man
you know right right and and especially
you know it's i'm obviously i'm not the
one making the decision it is not my
piece but i still
cannot imagine
it's actually a good point i cannot
imagine doing this you know you can
think one thing right but if you're
gonna give three first rounders and more
plus many many millions of dollars
plus
you know the public reaction will be
certainly notable uh if a trade does
happen
you better be sure and one way to be
sure is to do the extensive research
including getting a feel for what the
person is like um so i certainly do
understand from carolina's perspective
now you're mentioning three first
rounders right there is it possible
price could go down it certainly would
for me if i know that i'm the only team
that he would wave a no-trade clause for
you know and i understand that that that
the word that you you know just bringing
everything that you said
uh you know together ian is that if this
goes to next offseason there could be
other teams that would be willing to get
back in it
but nobody can get in it if the guy who
has a no trade clause is only willing to
waive it for one team
so wouldn't that kind of take away any
leverage nick casario has for wanting
dollar for dollar as opposed to cents on
it
no but i do think i i don't think that
would take away leverage i mean yes
miami the miami dolphins are in a good
position now but casirio's leverage is
he doesn't have to do the deal you can
really make a legitimate argument rich
that it makes sense for the texans to
wait and here are the reasons if they
wait they know what traffic they're
actually getting i like we trade deshaun
watson to let's say miami right now
you know they could reel off 11 straight
i don't know whatever week we're in 10
straight wins
and
devaluing the drastic that you just
received
if you trade in the offseason his play
won't affect the draft picks this year
uh also you have more teams and think
about it it's amazing i thought of this
the other day think about how many teams
are going to need a quarterback next
year like it's astounding how many like
i honestly probably eight or nine are
going to need a front line starting
quarterback there aren't that many so
the price of watson goes
up
plus you'll have more clarity on his
legal situation so there are arguments
that the texans could use to wait and
that really is their leverage even
though it seems there's only one team
what do you hear in there you're in the
seat of power the commissioner in his
press conference yesterday said that
they haven't received
enough information or access to enough
information or any information that
would lead to them putting him on the
commissioner's exempt list now or even
after a trade is made involving him what
are you hearing
um there
i mean i've been at these meetings
before everybody's talking i mean what
are you comfortable sharing what are you
hearing about that front
about his situation is legal resolving
that that is not a that is not a
surprise i mean the nfl has actually
been consistent and you know what the
way the reason roger goodell said it
like that is because he always wants to
reserve the right to
get more information and say okay well
now we're going to do this we're going
to just spend them we're going to put
them on the commissioner's example so
whatever happens you always want to keep
the door open and say we might get more
info the main point of what he said
yesterday which is that
watson is eligible like he didn't say
those words but that was the point that
if let's say the dolphins traded for
deshaun watson right now
um
he absolutely would be eligible to play
and that is the significant thing and
you know it's
i know there's all sorts of questions
like would he be suspended and all that
like
based on the information and there's
only two reasons you can be put in the
commissioner's examples and they are
very clear in the personal comment
policy
one
is if you are charged with a crime of
violence the two of you are charged with
a felony
there's three wisely three or the
commissioner suspects that any of those
things are going to happen based on his
information the watson case does not
rise to that level that is why it's not
an incentive
the internet report here on the rich
eisen show from the league meetings in
new york uh let's go uh injuries uh
injury-o-rama here starting with dak
mike mccarthy saying cooper rush getting
first team snaps this week but that's
normal that's part of a normal week
last time and we had the conversation
about dax uh health was back in the
preseason when we were kind of having
our fun with the mri being termed
precautionary you're like well guess
what it was it is so
i ask you how serious is the calf right
now for him
uh not that serious i i think he's going
to be okay it sounded like last week had
a really good week i know after
saturday's rehab session
i thought the cowboys were pretty
optimistic all the way
but after saturday's rehab session they
were very optimistic like i guess he had
a really good session he was in the pool
for most of the week um
it's impossible to say that without
thinking of costanza but
well there definitely would be shrinkage
on the scoreboard if it's cooper rush on
sunday night let's put it that way you
know you would assume i would say that
is uh yeah yeah i mean with all due
respect to google rush like this yes
okay that is correct
um
so but they think he's gonna be okay you
know was he gonna be like a thousand
percent mobile maybe not but like he
hasn't run that much this year anyway
i'd be pretty confident
um
i i'd i'd be pretty confident in knowing
what they're gonna get okay so you think
we're seeing him sunday night as we're
sitting here on a wednesday
that's what you're saying oh absolutely
okay all right there you go tj there you
go there's your answer you know and he
was right the last time so you were spot
on ian last time about his arm or back
or all that stuff you know one might say
i'm often right now
no one in my family or my wife yes but
some other people that's very good um
okay what's going on with antonio brown
is uh is his injury more serious than
believed is that the case in tampa
with him right now yeah
i mean he's on clutches that's not great
and the way bruce arians described it
is
is a little worrisome i have to be
honest like did you what he said he said
it's an ankle sprain but it's around the
heel
that is not a good description of an
injury especially if you have an
explosive player and like if you're if
you're about a heel injury and i
happen to have the privilege of one time
injuring my heel
not saying i'm quite like antonio brown
but i just i've also had a heel injury
it is terrible
um
so i would say yes this is a little
worrisome for the campaign
okay uh what's the latest on michael
thomas um
when do you think you said a couple
weeks ago that it would be more than a
couple weeks after he could uh come off
of injured reserve or pop right so
what's the plan for him because one
would think you know that that's a large
missing ingredient i mean we saw on
monday night uh an offense that was all
about making sure alvin kamara got the
ball in open space and things like that
but after a while one would think other
teams like maybe say the bucks would be
able to stop that more effectively than
seattle what do you think what's the
deal with michael thomas i mean
just first like from a big picture
situation
i thought jameis played well
there were some the receivers did not
help them at all right i mean they
couldn't get over the dimes out there
like and i'm not they didn't get over
they dropped it
right let's i'm not gonna like go there
where i had him in fantasy and i needed
him to have a big day and he actually
did it since his receivers let him down
and therefore i lost like i'm not going
to go into all that
but it would have helped me um
anyway
um michael thomas has been with the team
he has been rehabbing that is good news
and usually that would be no worthy but
remember he kind of went dark a little
bit last season leading to the situation
so he has been with the team he has been
rehabbing
his return is coming
uh it's
i don't know if it's going to be this
week but it is coming soon so i would
imagine
you know by november he is probably
going to be able to play barring some
sort of setback
um
i think that i think they're going to be
okay then i think they're going to get
him back soon okay christian mccaffrey
what about him panthers haven't won
since he left
the middle of that thursday night week
three game
in houston and sam darnold's been a
different player and i don't know if the
two are
related hard to know whether or not
they're related right like he's missing
throws that have nothing to do with
mccaffrey
um
it sounds like the goal is for him to be
back
right when ir ends like they almost
didn't put him on ir but then they did
just just to be cautious and make sure
when his back is 100 so you know his
medical situation has been
just frankly curious over the past
couple
years um
you know but i it sounds like when he is
eligible to come back he he will be able
to okay and russell what about russ you
hearing anything on russ wilson i mean
we saw him and with that sort of you
know covering on his hand and he he's a
sp
he looks like he's just
ready to go like he just can't get in
the starting box fast enough but do you
think seattle does get him back after
their bye in week 10. what do you think
about that one no when you say raring to
go do you mean because he does the
two-minute drill with like no one else
on the field before the game yeah that's
that's what i mean yeah yeah
for sure and that's totally normal right
just so we're clear
no ian it's not that's chris right there
chiming in what do you think
anyway
um
things are going well uh he's gonna have
the well with today's wednesday right he
should be having the pins out soon which
i think is good and then once that
he had i think it was three pins put
into his finger
um
which sounds horrible and that should be
i think it's either it's soon i think it
might even be today we'll we'll see when
it actually is but then you start the
rehab process so
the
best case scenario was week 10 against
the packers right i think that is still
possible if it's not i think week 11
should be fine which i think is against
the cardinals but i can't really
remember right um but things are going
well and like
you know i thought this was going to be
fine that gino would win a game or maybe
two and kind of hold it down obviously
it hasn't happened so like he needs to
come back and i would imagine this
pushes things even more than they were
already pushed okay last one for you on
on availability and things like that uh
is jalen hurts in danger of being
benched in philadelphia i mean you hear
all sorts of crazy stuff um but
for gardner minshew is it possible the
eagles want to just kick the tires on on
gardiner in any way shape or form what
are you hearing out of philly
you know i mean i can't ignore what
happened right which is joe flacco got
traded
um to your team
and
gardner mentioned became the backup that
is the step
i don't think they want to give up on
jalen hurts unless they absolutely have
to so if the season is out of reach if
they have nothing left to do
then i think that maybe minshew will
play then but i don't think it's going
to be a situation where they kind of
just turn to them and say oh we'll see
what happens like they want to give
jaylen hoods a fair shot they have not
yet committed to jaylen hurts as a as
their future starter nor should they
they don't need to
but it's pretty clear the door is open
there i think you know life would be
easier if jalen hurts was their
absolute sure starter
um
but i don't think they're there yet and
you know minshu has started in the nfl i
don't know that he was you know brett
favre like we all thought but certainly
there's something there maybe they catch
all the lightning in a bottle last one
for you ian rappaport uh the trade
deadline as we mentioned tuesday anybody
else we're just so obviously deshawn
watson-centric who else might get moved
what are you looking to see over the
next couple of minutes to keep an eye on
here melvin ingram with these steelers
is one um
lj collier the former first round over
the seahawks he is another
um
kyle fuller the
db from the broncos who they signed and
kind of fallen out of favor a little bit
he is another
um
andre gillard from the eagles who kind
of got replaced as the left tackle but
then played there one week and actually
did really well i think that would be
expensive but strongly possible
um that would be another so
you know i'm not sure it's like the most
star-studded trade deadline ever and no
one has any catchphrase so that doesn't
help but i think we may see a couple
things all right ian thanks for the call
brother you be well let's do this again
look for my call as always we'll chat
we'll chat you for the call
thank you guys
i'll chat sunday on game day morning
with you thanks ian that's uh ian
rappaport at rap sheet right here on the
rich eisen show in other words those
names that you just heard uh if i'm a
chiefs fan i'm like can we get that guy
can we get that guy hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here